(Forrest)
Gay people have existed
since people have existed.
And, yet, in all that time
I have never closely considered
who they are
or why they might need curing.
I chose to begin my review
with a fact-finding mission
to the gay sex shop
nearest my dad's house.
Who is that man?
(Forrest)
While there I was confronted
by a big realization.
- Mystified.
(Forrest) It was so enormous
I suddenly wondered if
this review was even possible
and I knew I had to consult
my producer Grant.
Completely mystifying.
Have you ever
looked closely
at a man's
flaccid penis?
It looks like something
that belongs
on the lightless
ocean floor
and what if, when a gay man
looks at a woman's
beautiful breasts,
he feels the same way.
That they're like
sea blobs with nipples on them.
I mean, if that's what
a gay man sees
when he looks at
a pair of breasts,
how am I supposed
to change that?
- It's impossible.
- Exactly.
What am I supposed to do?
Well, life is a parade of people
doing impossible things.
- Wha--
- Hey, when you quit this show
to go after your ex-wife
and she said it was too late
- and she rejected you...
- Yeah.
You vanished from
the face of the earth
until a dog found you
sleeping in a crawl space
- under a church.
- Yeah, it was a Rottweiler.
But what if I had told you
back then
that in less than a year
you would turn it all around.
You'd have your old job back,
you'd be dating a great
coma nurse.
Oh, well, eh, no,
she and I broke up.
Yeah, well,
that is exactly my point.
Because you don't
need her anymore
because
you're back out there,
you're living
a brand-new life.
So, if you can jump-start
a brand-new life,
why do you think
a gay person can't?
- Hmm.
- Are you so homophobic
that you don't think
a gay man can do what you do
just because he's gay?
No. Definitely gay men
can do everything I can do
and probably a lot better.
- Thank you for that.
- You get out there.
- Yeah.
- All right.